everyone and welcome to my first video
from
sochi russia i'm here for the friday
world cup
not as a player but as a photographer
and i got here what like three days ago
still recovering from
jet lag yesterday i i woke up at 2 am
fell asleep around like 11 p.m
a very long day but uh yeah the the feed
a world cup
and feed a women's world cup started
yesterday it was day one
round one there's over 300 players here
from all around the world
to compete and i thought i'd use this
video to
both share some photos of mine and then
also
share one of the best games
played in the first day so before we get
into the game
uh let me show some photos this is the
first
event i've photographed in a long time
i took probably close to a thousand
photos yesterday
between all like the high speed shots
but uh
i'll share some of the more notable ones
i'm pretty sure this is
who is this luis torres strong player
this was one of the last games to finish
this is a playing venue so it's held at
this
cool kind of space it kind of seems like
a space museum but it's also just an
event venue
have a very nice big room there's also
i took this from the stage so there were
players on the stage too
and there's so many players playing at
least in the first couple days that they
had a back room
to have more more matches as well
and there's a lot of notable players
here if i show
so this is this is a newly minted
grand master youngest grand master ever
abby manu mishra
who's up against obama in the first
round
uh joe bava is a fellow streamer very
strong ground master from georgia
inventor of the bava london
so i'll show i'll just show like a
slideshow of photos um
some of these are my my favorite shots
from
the tournament a lot of like cool chess
portraits
i think a lot of people should recognize
this person uh nemo
um her real name is zhao she's playing
for canada
and uh it's my first time actually
meeting her in person
so it's super cool and she's vlogging
the event i'll probably link below to uh
her youtube channel because she's doing
kind of more more
raw behind the scene vlog content but we
have a lot of
a lot of players i'll admit that i don't
recognize
i do recognize this person actually this
is a former teammate of mine was sifter
bailey
a grand master from azerbaijan we
competed together at webster university
yeah this is aniban who i also met for
the first time
also has a youtube channel so the
game i wanna show was played
by this guy and let me go back to the
game and i'll
explain who the players were yeah so the
game i want to show
was played between
[Music]
pablo salinas herrera who's pictured
here
he's a grand master from chile and he
was playing against another grandmaster
mads anderson uh from denmark
and we can see they're they're pretty
close in reading both above 2500
and very soon you'll see why this is
already probably going to be one of the
best games of the tournament
it featured a really cool i'll probably
include this in the youtube title
but it included a triple queen sacrifice
now i don't want to spoil too much more
so i'm going to hide the
notation and it started as
kind of a ready very slow ready opening
which eventually transposed into some
kind of english
semi-slav i think there's a lot of names
we can call this
thing light was delaying d4 which is a
fine way of playing it's not the most
active but
eventually they did get kind of a
queen's pawn opening
um so some kind of queens gambit
semi-slav
and the resulting position they got
after bishop b7 bishop b2
is actually a line that i used to play
myself many years ago
and this position gave me some memory
of my first time ever playing levy
rosman
in a tournament and right before i
started this recording i was trying to
dig up the game
i did find it it was played back
in 20 was it
2012 in rockville maryland
and if you look we see the opening
um slightly different move order but
we can see it was a almost exact same
thing
and yeah we both fee encado so we go
back to the game that was played
yesterday
it's pretty much the same line and the
thing about this line both sides have
some flexibility
of where to put their rooks in the
center
so the difference between my game with
levy and this game
is that these players chose slightly
different squares for the rook
in my game with levi he put his queen on
c7
and it eventually followed just a
different route
another thing i'll note i'll leave a
link to the licha study so if you want
to analyze this game in more depth
or my game with levy link will be below
and feel free to uh
to analyze as much as you want but going
back here
they were still following theory bishop
f1
c5 takes takes this has all been played
before
and if i just show the opening book
there's been a couple dozen games and
after c takes d4
i take z4 at first it looks
very pleasant for white because white's
playing against this iceland queen's
pawn
upon blocks of bishop on b7
now i think a lot of players even like
very strong players
would pick the white side because it's
very positional this pawn on
d5 is a long-term weakness um not to
mention there's ideas of knight i5
but the thing is the position is just
very imbalanced because even though
white has a better structure
black has more potential for
activity and also more space in the
center with a pawn and d5 black just
controls a bit more space
as a half open c file with the rook
aligned with
the white queen has potential for knight
e4
and we're going to see within the next
couple moves how quickly black manages
to pressure white's position uh starting
with
bishop b4 and it turns out white's queen
is just a bit misplaced
because now not only is there a pin on
the c file
but the queen along with the bishop are
both tied down to the knight on c3
which can't move so light's under
pressure here not to mention knight e4
is also coming
so white plays some a passive move
knight e2
and now knight e4 just increasing
pressure
and after a3 which is an attempt to
relieve the pressure black goes for a
pretty spectacular
combination starting with knight takes
f2
and this is actually a pretty thematic
tactic whenever
you have this double
queen rook battery on the e file and you
have a knight here
and the f pawn is only defended by the
king
then this is a common way to just go for
complete destruction
and take advantage of the fact that e
pawn is going to fall next
so this is where the fireworks really
begin white went ahead
and took the bishop on b4
if you take the knight you probably just
regret it after queen takes
on e3 if the king moves this way there
is
d4 in the bishop on b7 is unleashed
if the king moves this way i imagine
this will end
very very badly for white now i'll admit
i didn't do too much analysis so i'm not
entirely sure what the
knockout blow here is for black
but maybe we can take a moment and find
the best continuation
oh is it just
it's just queen f3 queen f3 looks nice
king g1 and then bishop here
almost checkmates something would have
to block on d4 if the night box on d4
takes takes yeah this is uh this is just
ending immediately it's about to get
made of here
so for that reason
white did not take the knights took the
bishop
but loses the bishop on h3
plays king f1 and here if we count
material
black is actually the one up a pawn
and hasn't sacrificed anything because
white white didn't take the knight which
was sacrificed
so black is doing very well here and
played
what looks to be the most logical move
in the position queen takes e3
uh just threatening main one and at
first it looks like white's just
completely dead
like how do you defend the may threat
along with just the pressure on
both open files basically for black but
then white came up with a move
which does muddy the water and puts the
ball of lack in black's chords
is to play queen f5 triple purpose move
defending the mate threat attacking the
knight in h3 and attacking the knights
on d7
both knights are undefended for black
and it is a question what should black
do
next so black played knight f6 which
looks to just give away the knight on h3
however if white takes a knight then
maybe this is a good exercise back to
move and
find the winning combination feel free
to pause the video if you don't see it
already
i will say it's maybe not super simple
to find
but it's just a matter of finding the
forcing moves for black
and keeping the initiative going so the
first move is queen f3
uh forcing king g1 and then knight g4
and it turns out black is uh is
completely winning here
because the threat is queen f2 uh
king h1 and then d4 unleashing the
bishop
and there's really just no good defense
for white if the rook moves to f1
then there's queen e3 the king has to
move
along the diagonal of the bishop and d4
will happen
and white's just crumbling probably just
getting made in a few moves so
um knight f6 was a nice
option for black because it makes it so
white can't take the
the knight on h3 and black is bringing
out another attacker
to try and destroy white on the king
side
so white went ahead played bishop c1
and this is where the real beauty really
begins
because for the rest of the game
black sacks a queen pretty much every
move
and this like this is not something that
you see every day
so i think we're we're just going to sit
back and
cherish the the beauty of what's about
to happen
black goes ahead and plays the amazing
knight g4 putting the knight on an
undefended square but also leaving the
queen hanging
white cannot take either seemingly free
piece
because of maiden one if the queen is
taken
this is a really really nice checkmate
this is actually a triple fork
but the fork's irrelevant because the
king is just dominated by
the knights not a mating pattern that
you see every day
and if the knight's taken then it's a
more kind of traditional
in your face checkmate with queen f2
so knight g4 was really really nice
of course white realized that the black
pieces can't be taken
went ahead and plays rook d3 hitting
the queen trying to win the queen and
not get mated
but then black plays another really
stellar move
on d4 and this is another kind of oh no
my queen moment
uh the queen it's attacked this time
twice
by the rookie bishop if it's taken by
either piece
knight h2 is then made just because
now the bishop on b7 controls is crucial
g2 square and the knights do the rest of
the dirty work
so it's incredible how well the black
especially the black minor pieces
coordinate in this position
of course along with the queen and the
rook and it's a common theme of
attacking
chess where the best attacks usually
involve
really good coordination from multiple
pieces and if you're the attacker you
want to get as many pieces
involved as possible so white tried to
resist
one more move played rook to
d1 trying to give the king a square
to retreat but now we see
just a simply spectacular finish
and i'm going to pose the final sequence
as an exercise for viewers
uh this is black to move and made into
by force okay get ready for it
get ready for it queen g1
oh no my queen oh no pablo's queen
and this time unlike the previous few
positions
white is uh is forced to take the queen
its only legal move
um and now big respect to
mads anderson um who can't even be mad
about
uh the result in this game given how
beautiful the ending is
um he didn't resign usually like when
the grand master has force made it's
typical etiquette to resign but when the
maid is so beautiful
i think it usually says you should play
it out until uh
until checkmate which is what white did
in this position
knight takes g1 and then just as
sensational
knight takes h2 check and mate
this time the rook is involved it was
very crucial that
after the knight takes back the rook
then controls
the last getaway square from the white
king
and this is game over and i won't be
surprised if this turns out to be
like the best game of the whole event
even though we're just one day in given
how many times black
tried to give away the queen finally did
give away the queen
and won in beautiful style
so i really hope you guys enjoyed that i
don't know how many recap videos i'll
have time to do
just because the schedule's haptic i'll
be taking
a lot of photos uh of like every day
so be sure to keep an eye on
the flickr album instagram and twitter
will be the main place
that photos are posted and big congrats
once again
to pablo salinas for a sensational game
i took this photo before the game
actually started so he's looking very
serious
but if you watch his interview after the
game he was uh
he was just full of adrenaline and
excitement
so with that thanks for watching and
i'll see you
in the next video